now according to news reports pastor
Brunson is the 19 prisoner perhaps
hostages the right word freed by the
Trump administration
here's pastor Brunson praying with the
president at the White House over the
weekend take a look o God I ask that you
pour out your Holy Spirit on President
Trump that you give him supernatural
wisdom to accomplish all the plans you
have for this country and for him I ask
that you give him wisdom now to lead
this country and to righteousness
joining us now is Pastor Brunson himself
pastor I'm so glad you're out I know how
many worked on your behalf talked about
your case off and Jay Sekulow the
president you were held for 18 months
and had no reason no understanding why
and you were held in a Cell designed for
eight and there were 21 people correct
yes for part at that time it was a very
crowded crowded cell and part of the
time I was also in isolation so it was a
very difficult time and I was surprised
because I had never really considered
prison as a possibility and counted the
cost for that yeah
how are you treated sir I was treated
well by the prisoners I was with and
they were all they would not of your
faith they weren't and that was one of
the very difficult things is it I was
isolated by culture and by language but
especially by religion and it was very
difficult to be the only Christian among
them when you found out what you were
being held for which was your faith what
did you think well what was surprising
is that they told me that I was being
helped for terrorism and for trying to
overthrow the government and the truth
is that we had been preaching Jesus
Christ sir that's why we were in Turkey
for 23 years up until that time is to
share the gospel of Jesus Christ with
Turks we've done that openly and never
had a problem so it was very shocking to
be accused of terrorism well and and
also but it really came down to your
Christian faith in many ways which is
and I thought your prayer was
extraordinarily touch
but with the president I want to talk
about your worst moment because I can
imagine that when you lose your freedom
you pretty much lose everything
especially in a foreign country not
being known why not knowing why you're
even being held and you know not having
anyone to share your faith your values
with you what was your lowest moment
well when I was arrested and it kept
going on and on and it seemed that there
was no way out and I lost a lot of hope
and what helped me I began to see that
there was value and my suffering
especially as time went on I saw that
many people around the world began
praying for me and I began to see that
God knows I doubt about that how did you
hear about that well this was especially
through my wife because she was the only
contact I really had with the outside
world and she could visit me for about
half an hour every week through a glass
and speaking on the phone and she would
bring encouragement to me and told me
that people were praying for me and as I
learned that I began to see that God was
involved in this and that God was going
to do something with my suffering that
had to say this morning in an interview
I'm one of the most hated men in Turkey
probably well I've been accused of
trying to overthrow the government of
being aligned with the the Fethullah
Gulen terrorist movement also being part
of the PKK which is a Kurdish guerrilla
terror movement and also was blamed for
the economic problems Turkey had so
there probably are not too many people
who like neither right now have to let's
talk about that moment that touched a
lot of people you're a man of great
faith and and obviously a strong
Christian and you prayed for the
president's talk about that moment
well it's something that we had hoped to
be able to do my wife had for some time
wanted to pray some verses over him from
Isaiah just asking for the Spirit of God
to come upon him and before we went to
meet him when we learned we would be
able to visit him in the White House we
prayed together my wife and I and asked
God to give us that opportunity to pray
for the president and it's a great
privilege I think many pastors would
love to do it
and our president needs prayer you know
pastor we're glad you're home
for you and your family it was a very
touching moment I think all of us I'll
start with me could use more God in our
lives and I think you impact a lot of
people
welcome home sir we're glad to have you
back thank you and I want to thank you
for keeping you in the news while I was
in prison I appreciate it very welcome
to do it sir
Jay Sekulow did an amazing job the
president stood strong and thank god
you're here